Philippe briillot Le Maire d'iver droite
du chînet a semé le trouble la semaine
dernière en faisant voter une motion par
son conseil municipal pour refuser en
l'état le projet de loi sur le mariage
homosexuel une question de société qui
semble donc faire débat et nous avons
voulu savoir quelle était la position
des élus de l'agglomération il y a
d'abord ceux qui sont ouvertement pour
et l'ont même affiché en mairie de Guill
encour par exemple un Pax entre deux
femmes y a été célébré c'est tout à fait
juste légitime et c'est simplement
marqué que les homosexuels sont des
citoyens comme les autres n'oublions pas
que ça concerne 100000 plus de 100000
couple
homosexuel en France et que en dans le
monde 11 pays l'ont déjà adopt ce
mariage homosexuel et sur quatre
continents il faut donc s'adapter aux
réalités une réalité aussi pour les
maires de la verrière et maniléamo à
partir du moment où dans notre société
moderne s'organise les choix individuels
donc le choix de vivre ensemble quel que
soit le sexe et bien on peut aller
effectivement jusqu'à la reconnaissance
parce que ça donne des droits ce sont
des droits finalement c'est la
reconnaissance des droits ça fait partie
du programme du Parti socialiste et donc
de François Hollande et de la majorité
gouvernementale donc c'est une avancé de
la société vers l'égalité donc c'est le
mariage pour tous il y a aucun souci
pour nous attrape le socialiste affiche
une position plus nuancée pour lui la
question est complexe quant aux élus de
droite de l'agglomération ils sont
également mesuré et en tout cas il
souhaite établir un débat c'est un débat
que j'auraai avec mes élus mais encore
faut-il déjà que nous puissions avoir
des bases de réflexion puisque aucun
texte de loi à ce jour n'a été voté et
en tout cas je n'ai pas vu celui qui est
en préparation même si Michel logier
attend de consulter son équipe
municipale certains au sein de C
celles-ci ont déjà pris position c'est
le cas du conseiller municipal Mathieu
Colombani proche de Christine Boutin il
souhaite un référendum Mathieu Colombani
a tweté en tant que Matthieu Colombani
aujourd'hui en tant que élu de Montini
il n'a pas encore participé à un débat
quel qu'il soit au sein de l'équipe
municipale la question du référendum un
autre élu s'interroge le maire de voisin
le Bretonneux il estime que ce débat
n'arrive pas au bon moment ce sont des
questions en fait que je me pose en tant
en tant que maire
hein est-ce le
moment de d'aborder ce sujet-là alors
qu'on est dans une très très grave crise
on a dépassé les 3 millions de chômeurs
alors la deuxème question que je me pose
c'est
a-t-on consulté les
maires ce sont les Mair de France et
leurs adjoints qui célèbrent les les
mariages
les attend
consultter le maire d'élancour
Jean-Michel Fourgous estime également
qu'il y a d'autres problèmes à régler en
France et il reconnaît des
questionnements au sein de son équipe le
débat est donc loin d'être clos une loi
sur le mariage homosexuel devrait être
présenté en